liberals attacking Elon Musk for simply
seeing the Carnage at the border the
billionaire going where Joe Biden
refuses and live streaming his trip to
Eagle Pass Texas on X the town gets
routinely bombarded by thousands of
illegal immigrants the Tesla CEO getting
a tour from Republican Congressman Tony
Gonzalez
and they say it's not just women and
children Crossing
what we're seeing here are in some cases
some pretty extreme uh
uh individuals coming through
um obviously not suggesting everyone is
like this but you're talking about
um you know a guy who came through uh
who had face tattoos including tears yes
at tattooed on his face yes the tear
when somebody tattoos are tear it means
that they they have murdered someone
yeah and they are so proud of the having
murdered someone that they they tattoo
like one tear on their face for every
person that they kill is that correct
that's exactly right I mean these are
this person just claimed Asylum claim to
sign and we just let them in we let them
in most likely if if they were murdering
people somewhere else and proud of it
they will continue in that tradition
that's exactly right predictably the
liberal media and the Democrats are
freaked out that musk is exposing
Biden's border crisis and MSNBC anchor
says how dare law enforcement host the
billionaire and AOC is trying to snitch
on the Republican congressman who showed
Elon around the Border and while
liberals bashed musk for going there
others like this squad rep are flat out
denying there's a problem at all
no doubt about it uh our border is
secure and we're in the midst of
humanitarian crisis and we have to fix a
broken system you think it is secure you
think the border is secure or it is not
secure yes the border is secure but if
you have millions of undocumented
migrants coming into the country how is
the border secure Jake this is not a new
crisis it just seems like
just such a a refusal to acknowledge
reality all right so Greg why do you
think the Press is mad that musk is
doing the job they should be doing I
just love Jake's expression though it
looks like he's smelling something
really bad but it
to the Border
nobody follows the media doesn't follow
right they don't have to because it's
Fox but if musk goes It's News he's fly
paper to these lazy saps and he knows it
this is the only way it can happen so
musk is because musk is like a trump
substitute uh uh for the routine of
mockery for for the time being he knows
that if he goes to the Border they will
follow him but when they do the story
it's not about the Border it's now musk
is at the border and so what are these
finger sniffers report on you got to
read the headlines it's like his live
streaming was written with riddled with
glitches and he wore his cowboy hat
backwards so that's their investigative
reporting well if you don't like how
he's doing it why don't you do it you
d-bags why don't you do your job so he
doesn't have to go but but you won't so
he goes and now you cover it musk is
essentially fulfilling a role that for
the last three years has been vacant
president he's on the Forefront of Beach
he's on the Forefront of immigration
he's on the Forefront of parental rights
while our so-called commander-in-chief
is you know renovating his house using
money from China so he's stepping up
because apparently our
commander-in-chief doesn't give a damn
he does the bigger story now is because
he's doing this the government is
targeting him they're going after him
they're suing him based on stuff that
he's not even aware of and the reason is
they know he's immune because he's the
world's richest man so they're going to
use their Legion of operatives and
minions to take him down and limit his
speech like he's the most dangerous
person in the world to the Democrats and
to the left and he's also the most
important chess piece on the chessboard
and they got to take him out rather than
just simply listening to them they got
to destroy him if he were a leftist he
would be safe but unfortunately in order
to be have free speech and be able to
speak truth to power you got to be a
billionaire maybe musk should go here
and look at the migrant settlements
maybe he should go to the same San
Francisco homeless tents we should just
send them everywhere and then the media
has to report on it well did you hear
that mayor Adams in New York City is
apparently he's got signs out saying if
you're an immigrant you're better off
going to a more more affordable City
okay as if we are paying for their
housing their education their medication
and everything they need
um look the truth is that Elon Musk is
an immigrant who is a self-made
billionaire who has a company in Texas
who has every right to go to the border
and the truth is that the Democrats are
not going to the border and when Elon
goes to the Border then the Press goes
to the border and they just don't want
the border to be seen and amazingly Joe
Biden is in Arizona at the same time and
won't go anywhere near the border and so
you know the only time that AOC is
making fun of both Elon and the uh the
congressmen who took him there is in
2019 when she did this fake she was
crying because you know she thought the
children were in cages that's because
Donald Trump was a president she hasn't
been there since you know this is such a
political back and forth and Ayanna
Presley over there with Jake Tapper
saying the border is secure I mean The
Gaslight us they absolutely look right
at us and say of course the border is
secure this is a humanitarian crisis a
Jay Johnson who was the head of Homeland
Security in 2019 says we now know what a
thousand illegals look like when we get
to 4 000 a day then we're not going to
be able to handle it well right now
we're at 10 000 a day and we cannot
handle it you know when the fires ripped
through Maui all the networks went CNN
went MSNBC went because that's a sexy
location and they can stay at a nice
place it's very difficult to fly from
New York and DC down to South Texas down
to the border and they don't want to go
there's nowhere nice to stay the
backdrop's not good that has a lot to do
with it Harold it may it's good to be
back with you a couple couple of quick
things one anyone has the right to go to
the Border you're right uh your honor uh
and anyone democrat or republican it
says otherwise or any network it says
otherwise is just wrong it reminds me
when I listened to my friend
congresswoman from Massachusetts and
she's a friend but when when Republicans
when guns something happens with a gun
and some Republicans say there's no gun
issue we don't have to react to it but
when I think that's wrong I'm going to
Democrat says there's nothing going on
at the border that it's secure that's
just not credible we have a challenge at
our border and we've got to deal with it
I appeal to all my friends old friends
and and those I didn't serve Within
Congress don't shut the government down
the next day or so or if you do car
about funding for the military and for
federal law enforcement including our
border security officials for all of us
who are concerned about it but the
politics aside for one woman if we if
they miss a paycheck or we go a day or
two over the problem could worsen now
the problem's been screaming at us for a
long time and we've sat around and say
by the way I like that Fred Perry Oh
wait thank you the wall sending the
military down Greg Federman
[Laughter]
finding ways to reform the Asylum
process I think will hurt this
Republican running for president has
said it well you have to reverse that
you don't automatically get to come in
because you're applying for Asylum
that's one of the legal issues that
Shannon knows well that you have to
address uh and you got to figure out how
you how you help some of these law
enforcement agencies in these other
countries the ones that are not corrupt
the ones that don't have governance
challenges but I pushed back on anyone
that says that Elon Musk didn't have the
right to go to border and I think you
may be right he had to go to Chicago and
talk about crime he had to go to San
Francisco and talk about crime and
frankly he had to go to some places and
talk about race relations as well it
might help might help solve some of
those problems yeah he's showing a lot
of leadership so when you have these
Democrats on your Sunday show do you ask
them is the border secure when they say
it is what do you say well here's the
thing there are Democrats who have been
saying it's not secure you've got the
Henry cuars of the world who is a
congressman out of Texas and I find it
interesting that any member of Congress
would say what Texas Congressman
shouldn't be down there talking about
the Border I mean this is a nonstop top
issue why wouldn't they be drawing
attention to it
and the richest man in the world is in
Texas and wants to see it you're gonna
show up and show them and and by by Elon
being there doesn't box out anybody else
like I don't know why people are
outraged like everybody is free to go
see it for themselves and these members
have had to get creative trying to get
the attention of the white house uh
there's a piece now of legislation in
the house by two members one from Texas
one from New York and what they're
saying is these cities like New York
City which is now getting overwhelmed
cannot ask for federal funding if they
had declared themselves Sanctuary cities
right you can't make that declaration
draw people in and then now say you need
more Federal money so these members of
Congress are just going to try to attack
it any way they can and that includes
getting attention how do you know if the
cowboy hats backwards I don't know that
was what they were claiming it's
probably wrong yeah he probably had it
on the right way hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else